hey guys my name is Jess and today's
been completely packed full of links
ahead of all the e3 announcements were
expecting so here's a roundup of the
biggest things that happened it brought
to you by Qualcomm Snapdragon LTE modem
support epically fast LTE speed
as for things that came out when
publishers intended for them to we got
brand-new story details and a gorgeous
trailer for Mass Effect Andromeda p for
17 we'll have a story mode and we got
the confirmation that titanfall 2 would
indeed be getting a single-player
campaign and titans and pilots are both
due to get new abilities although to be
fair that one did also leak right before
ea's press conference this morning in
other leaky 3 news a picture has popped
up on NeoGAF that appears to show off
the rumored new Xbox one model it's
allegedly called the Xbox one s will be
forty percent smaller than the original
model with a two terabyte hard drive and
support HDR and 4k video as for the
games screenshots from dead rising for
halo awards to CGI and recore arrived
ahead of the Microsoft press conference
leaks gameplay arrived from Dishonored 2
which shows off the ominous outsider and
protagonist Emily called ones
supernatural abilities we were also
treated to a lovely-looking artwork
leaked from the new zelda game which
displays the game's massive open world
and Link climbing this way up a rock
face that is just a selection of all the
gaming news that landed today so be sure
to check back to gamespot for everything
in between and coverage of all the
upcoming conferences
you